donnant vie aux journaux se trouve sur
your des restaurateurs ça fait environ
600 années qu'on n'a pas fini de sur ce
jeu elle nous a manqué on lui a manqué
je suis pas sûr aujourd'hui messieurs
dames nouveautés extraordinaire une
nouvelle arme c'est bien que les armes
sont sur la droite qu'on arrive à
l'école n'y avait donc qu'un couteau un
ciseau un katana à cutter un tournevis
et maintenant il y a c'est pas ici et
maintenant et via un saut oui ça pue la
merde basse excellence exemple parfait
soldat mais que ce soit parce que quoi
de plus discret comme arme qu'un saut on
va le prendre on va le remplir avec de
l'eau on va redescendre voir tous nos
petits copains qui sont en train de
parler où il ya des surprises et en
fleurs et on va aller brûler ces faux
attention technique de forme numéro une
saison à aimar d'une copine à vous elles
sont toutes à un train de se parler
ouais t'as vu la meuf la nouvelle elle
est bizarre bla bla bla ah ouais et
bastien g pape extraits [ __ ] merde à
bien en a qu'une qui prendra ce toujours
la même a sérieusement fait plus
attention aux doigts tu baisse d'un ton
on la suit hélas quoi faire ça va être
vraiment génial on va pas la tuer on va
pas la tuer
bon on va la tuer elle se dirige vers
les douches mais pour quoi faire me
direz-vous elle va essayer de se sécher
à l'aide d'un sèche-cheveux peut-être
déjà on la voit un poil c'est toujours
très correct parce que putallaz des
boobs tellement énorme cette femme et la
caisse quoi faire bas les photos on va
se régaler au sens vrai je m'avoue
mentir ça sert à rien suspens de plaisir
aux plats toujours plus de bull va la
prendre en photo devant aux places qui
va c'est qu'elle s'emballe estate bravo
l'album aucune pudeur on peut la prendre
en photo vue du dessus ça ce sera la
miniature en plat ni vu ni connu
il ya du sang sur nous on va abandonner
la remet ici voilà juste à côté d'elle
ces six décès bien sidéens se mettant un
coup comme ça on a déjà vu des gens
faire ça les samouraïs préféré sourire
le vent de tokyo perd leur honneur à ta
mère du coup il faut qu'on se bouge plus
on se met nu on se douche vite fait bien
fait ok on sait d'où chez hélène il
faudra un uniforme nouveau on va lui
voler le sien je peux pas écouter j'ai
une autre idée va prendre sa [ __ ] de
dépouilles et on va montrer aux autres
ce qui va leur arriver s'il touche
annonce m aux mondiaux j'étais en train
de me doucher et d'un coup j'ai vu cette
oui je sais c'est terrible elle m'a mis
nu avant de mourir j'ai pas compris
pourquoi est bon notre et les billets à
chier reprise on allait voilà tout a
foiré ok ok ok maintenant la version
afghans un [ __ ] de bidons d'essence on
va verser dans le sauront
ensuite on prend le sont
mais tu as oublié dont manque un truc et
oui les amis il nous faut avant de
pouvoir faire ça des allumettes pour
[ __ ] le feu à l'essence a on peut
commander à ce mec mystérieux qu'est une
[ __ ] de tête de pervers des choses
dont une boîte d'allumettes
oui mais pour cela il faut lui envoyez 5
photos de culotte
tous à vos appareils blanche
ok apprécié de baver dessus à fond on va
maintenant pouvoir demander une faveur à
cet immense pervers hop une boîte
d'allumettes c'est parti par contre
gersois où je les reçois par par
colissimo par chronopost ou oui les
envoyer à lui m [ __ ] ou sous évalué m
oh oh oh qu'est ce que c'est que ça
c'est des [ __ ] d'allumettes mon gars
eh ouais de retour de la violence
j'ai transporté 1 tous les sens les
personnes ne se posera des questions et
offre assez d'essence ou du sens c'est
du sang je suis victime d'un complot la
non mais je sais que suis je loue mais
là vraiment c'est la vérité il y avait
de l'essence dans le souk on l'a posée
tout à l'heure qui avait du sens dans ce
souk est qu à l automne d'erika volumes
chaînés là ça part en couille moi
j'arrête après va débarquer ici alors
voir des buts et on arrête tout c'est
reparti pour prendre dès qu en photo
ok ok ok on se calme on a de quoi
demander les à lui 2 mais j'en ai envoyé
5 i'll make him to you please est un
gros pervers ok on a les a lui même est
ok on a les sens pardon ok on allait
transporter de l'essence sais pas
pourquoi mais en tout cas je pas
coupable quoi ça sans quoi ça sent
l'essence
ouais c'est sa petite fdp est maintenant
au maire d'assat fait bien là est partie
par ok on avoir la preuve filature la
préfecture de la bruine on va la
brunette brûle brûle mais n'a pas alors
fréquemment dans le bain non je dis tout
le temps je tout le temps j'ai tout le
temps cris autre qui est tombé en plus
elle brûle au csad quand il est avec
nous et brut dont nous c'est adorable
belle et on peut poser quand même que tu
as bull elle s'inquiète pas trop à l as
apic invite à son petit but non mais
sérieux là non mais elle est déjà je
tiens à dire parce que je suis physicien
mi-temps les sens ça brûle quand même
dans l'eau un papa ce cadre le iphone ce
cas de lock ça est un essence qui brûle
un mais [ __ ] mais je fais là buté mais
laisse moi de faire une petite carte
juste une allumette une petite cicatrice
une allumette parties à l'ets non mais
là j'ai accepté je n'accepte pas là ce
qui se passe c'est à dire qu'en fait tu
vas non non non non mais tu vas pas de
changer mais tu crois que tu vas partir
incognito vas-y pas vas-y tiens tiens
très bien j'ai compris on va la jouer
plus discret et plus facile ici nous
avons des poids on va les mettre dans ce
saut voilà où les âmes attend les biceps
alors maintenant avec se sont emballés
sur le toit c'est comment ça va finir
tiens tiens mais qu'est ce qu'elle fait
ou téléphone didon c'est pas bien ça hop
je vais lâcher ce soit ici ou là elle
lui met des coups de genoux pour
l'achever où elle a semblé mal ça tu vas
appelé la police bappel la police moi je
tends à discuter avec mon ami que ça
stéphanie mon ami stéphane udry olala je
transporte encore de l'essence
je suis tellement désolée pardon je
transporte des allumettes et en
attention ça va parfois j'en ai marre tu
vas brûler maintenant on anticipe ou
quoi là on attend ces partis religieux
sur cette photo me sanjeev pour cette
photo de kokoda qui brûlent dix villes
pour celle ci parce que voyez vous avez
vous besoin nous semble bon ben c'est
pas ce texte aux bulls annonce avec les
déchets ne suis pas inquiet je marche
sur le corps de coco n'a tout brûler
allez viens avec nous what's up les
filles
voici ce qui vous arrivera si vous étiez
très chaud sempai que ce soit clair
voilà si vous avez fait vous pouvez
taper dedans je sais moi qui offre aux
plages pour le saut et g
salut je pense qu'on devrait faire
spectacle de magie toi et moi et
lorsqu'après les sénateurs n'hésitez pas
allez messieurs vous a plu et s'ils
voulaient taper dans un petit mot les
cui de coco chevaux s'appelle ont sans
doute rêvé dans une prochaine vidéo on
termine sur cette merveilleuse image du
corps brûlés c'est affreux on va quand
même gardé une petite photo souvenir ont
montré qu'elle a voulu faire la mère de
michael jackson
elle est passée de blanc un noir profond
turcs ont fini sur une blague de merde à
la tenue prochaine de portez vous bien
le château monde pis